HELGA: Hi, my name is Helga and I’m from Iceland.
Election day in Iceland is always on a Saturday
and the government encourages people to vote.
Election day is also always in the summertime,
so no one is weather-trapped or can’t
make it because of bad weather conditions.
FATIMAH: Hi everyone, my name is Fatimah.
I’m from Ecuador and I just want to let
you know a little bit about how voting is on
election day. It’s actually mandatory to vote,
which I think is great, and on
that day you get an appointment
on a location that you need to vote
on. Normally it happens on Sundays.
You don’t really get a lot of lines because it’s
already pre-registered with your ID number. The
polls happen continuously around the day, and
then you get the results at the end of the day.
SIERRA: Voting is one of the few things that I
actually remember really clearly from my early
childhood. Our polling place was in my elementary
school, which was closed for the occasion,
so this meant it was all dim and quiet.
My mom would take me into the booth and
she would close the curtain behind us. And
there was this air of excitement, you know,
and seriousness in there. She’d tell me which
candidates to choose and I would flip the heavy
switches and then at the very end we would
pull the lever together. In the United States,
only 55 percent of the eligible population voted
in the 2016 election. In terms of a test grade,
that’s a hard fail, and one that puts us
far behind most of the democratic world.
There’s a certain irony there. The U.S.
is the world’s oldest modern democracy.
Over the centuries it inspired dramatic
democratic shifts across the globe - and
its constitution was regularly used as a model in
the process. And yet now, after teaching so much,
the U.S. finds itself with a lot to learn on a key
democratic function. My name is Gabrielle Sierra,
and this is Why It Matters. Today, why the United
States lags on voter turnout and what can be done.
Laura Flanders:
The most important election in a
generation is fast approaching.
TODAY Show: America’s most basic
civic duty can and will go on.
Chasing News:Election day.
KRIS 6 News: Election day.
Associated Press: Election day in America.
BECKER: There is no question that when more
citizens of a democracy are invested in that
democracy through the act of voting that democracy
is more legitimate, it's more functional.
I'm David Becker. I'm the executive director and
founder for the Center for Election Innovation
and Research in Washington, DC. We're
a nonpartisan nonprofit that works with
election officials all over the country
and all across the political spectrum
to make elections that are more secure
and accessible for all American voters.
And I think it's also important to note that the
adversaries of democracy—autocracies around the
world—want citizens and democracies to disengage.
They want them to believe that they cannot trust
their election outcomes, that their elected
leaders are illegitimate, and the democracy is
not working as a form of government. And that's
why it's more important than ever, that the
world's democracies fight against these things and
work to get their citizens engaged and involved.
DIXON: Gabrielle, I think voter turnout
is a sign of people's engagement with
democratic politics. So by itself, it's a
key indicator of the health of a democracy.
SIERRA: This is Rosalind Dixon,
professor of law at the University
of New South Wales in Sydney - which is
coincidentally my study abroad alma mater.
She is also a visiting
professor at Harvard Law School.
DIXON: But it's also really important to
making sure that politics functions to
meet the needs of citizens. If people don't
turn out to vote, their voices aren't heard,
their needs are less likely to be factored in, in
the democratic process. And that's particularly
important if there's a systematic skew, whereby
some voters time after time, don't show up,
politicians start counting on that, and they don't
design policies around those citizens' needs.
CLARKE: I like to just do that reality check
and really situate the United States in a global
framework. And I think it's sobering to see that,
in so many respects, we deem the United States to
be one of the leading democracies across the globe
but we're not when it comes to voter participation
and voter turnout by any stretch. My name is
Kristen Clark. I'm the President and Executive
Director of the Lawyers Committee for Civil Rights
Under Law. And that's because we make it really
hard. We make it really hard for people to get
registered, we make it hard for people to vote,
we make it hard for them to stay on the rolls,
and we have very fractured systems where we've
got 50 states that all have their own separate
rules and approaches. And, you know, it's unlike
other major democracies around the globe that
have more uniform systems, and that are really
about making it easy for people to participate.
BECKER: In a presidential election we'll normally
see about 60 percent of eligible voters
participate. That's the high watermark in
general for voter turnout. In other elections,
such as midterm elections, the elections for
Congress in between presidential elections,
we’ll normally see turnout around 40 percent,
give or take. And then in a primary election it
might only be about 25 or 30 percent. And since
those are split between the parties, Democratic
and Republican parties, in order to win a primary
election, it might actually be a very small
number of voters who have actually selected
the candidate that is going to be one of the two
who will become president. And that's exactly
what we saw in 2016. Only about fifteen million
people in the Republican Party voted for Donald
Trump to be their nominee. And yet, because of how
primaries work, that was enough votes for him to
advance to the general election as the Republican
nominee. And to be perfectly honest, Secretary
Clinton got about the same number of votes and
achieved the Democratic nomination. So this is
where people opting out of voting, whether by
choice or just inertia, can make a big difference
SIERRA: According to a 2018 PEW
study, Belgium has the world’s best
rate of voter participation, with 87
percent. Sweden is right behind with
nearly 83 percent. Denmark and Australia
also top the charts. The United States,
again, sits at 55 percent, placing 26th out of
32 advanced democracies. There are no simple
answers about why. But part of the problem is
that many Americans don’t even attempt to vote.
BECKER: I think, for many voters, they just don't
know what the point of their vote is, why does it
matter? And we've had a hard time articulating
why their vote matters. Your vote doesn't matter
because you're likely to cast the one ballot
that's going to be the deciding vote in a race,
almost nobody is going to ever vote in a race
where one vote is going to choose. It happens,
but it happens extremely rarely. If you
ask voters in the United States if they're
registered and if they vote, more will say
they are registered and more will say they
vote than actually do. In other words, some are
lying. And some people get depressed about that,
I actually think that's a good sign, it means that
people already know that something they should do.
They don't need to be convinced that voting is a
good thing. They don't need to be convinced that
participation is a good thing. But they're not
doing it, and that tells me that we just need to
get them more engaged. You know, why do one-third
of the voters who participate in the presidential
election not participate two years later in a
congressional election? We don't really have a
good answer for that and that's literally tens of
millions of people. About forty to fifty million
people didn't participate in 2014 after they did
vote in 2012. They were mostly registered. They
mostly knew about the election. They knew how to
vote. They'd use the technology, but they didn't
show up. These are all things we really need to
figure out and we don't have great answers on.
SIERRA: There is no single explanation for
non-voters, and experts like David Becker
have dedicated their careers to understanding the
question. That said, there are some trends. The
Knight Foundation’s 100 Million Project found
that 38 percent of non-voters feel that the
election systems are rigged, that their vote has
no impact, and that the U.S. government does not
represent the will of the people. Additionally,
non-voters reported that they don’t engage as
actively with news, and feel that they are
not equipped with enough information to vote.
Knight Foundation: I don’t think I’m gonna vote
because I’m not informed on anything. I haven't
done any research so I feel like my vote’s gonna
be wasted. I feel like being young and voting,
people will judge you for it because you’re
not educated enough about the whole voting
process. I don't think my vote matters. I think
the whole thing is predetermined. The idea of
voting is kinda like a, like a scheme.
SIERRA: Studies like the 100 Million
project point to deep psychological
and educational barriers to voting. Beyond
these, according to experts, there are also
several systemic factors that can stand in
the way even after someone decides to vote.
One of these problems is that in the
United States voting can be...complex.
CLARKE: We get a lot of calls to our 866 Our
Vote hotline from people asking basic things
like “What's the deadline for registering to
vote?” “How do I register?” “Can you register to
vote online?” “Can I get access to an absentee
ballot? Am I eligible?” I think that we can do
a much better job at voter education. But then
there's a different form of voter education and
that's really understanding what you need to
cast an effective ballot. Are there going to
be three or four ballot amendments that require
that you read through a long narrative and vote
yes or no? There's this phenomenon in our country
where we see huge drop offs as people make their
way down the ballot. In a presidential election
year, you may see very high participation rates
at the presidential level, maybe for your state
governor, and then just a huge drop off as you
get down to things like the State Commissioner on
Education and the Tax Assessor and the Sheriff,
these are positions that absolutely
have impact on our day to day lives.
SIERRA:Right. So I probably shouldn't be standing
outside my polling place, Googling what each of
these positions, even does, let alone the
name of the candidates that are up for it.
CLARKE: I've found myself in that position,
too, where I'm whipping out my phone, you know,
at the ballot box here in DC. But some states
actually impose time limits on how long you can
stay inside and vote. So you only have so much
time to do that research on the spot. Yeah.
SIERRA: Sometimes when you see media coverage of
long lines for early voting, let's say in Georgia,
or elsewhere, you might hear people say, you
know, “This is democracy in action! These people
are patiently waiting to have their voices heard!”
You know, what are the problems with those lines?
CLARKE: They discourage people. I went to my
bank the other day and there was a line that
stretched halfway down the block. I turned around,
I didn't have what looked to be like an hour, hour
and a half to wait that line out. So these lines
that you see during our elections, to me, are
heartbreaking. I understand that kind of reaction
of it being a sign that democracy is alive and you
know, people are participating in high numbers,
and that's part of the story. But the other part,
when you when you look closely, is that oftentimes
there are breaks in the system. Georgia is one
example of that. Georgia was a mixed tale of
people really turning out historic numbers,
but we dealt with the complaints. People who told
us about sites that just were not up and ready in
the morning, poll books that were not working
so people couldn't get checked in properly. So,
you know, officials often are not coming through
for voters in the way that we need them to.
SIERRA: Do you think that there's an argument that
making voting easier also makes the
process more susceptible to fraud?
CLARKE: I've got a good friend, Justin Levitt,
who teaches out in California who determined
that you've got a better chance of being struck
by lightning than seeing fraud play out in our
elections. These claims about vote fraud are
really used and touted as a narrative to drive
fear, to create the impression that we need
to have really strict rules and burdensome
requirements that make it super hard for people
to vote to prevent fraud. There really just is
no evidence of fraud being a widespread problem
in our country and it's just a distraction from
the real problem, which is that there are far too
many Americans who don't vote, who can't vote,
who are unable to vote, because of the enormous
obstacles and burdens that we put in their way.
SIERRA: These obstacles
are part of a long history.
CLARKE: Voting in our country has always
been hotly contested ground. Our nation
has a fraught history of denying
Black people access to the ballot,
denying women access to the ballot for
a period of time, and we've had a long
struggle to try and push for all communities
to gain full access to the franchise.
BECKER: I mean, it is literally fifty-five
years ago that the Voting Rights Act of 1965
was passed. And that was passed
because a very large percentage
of American citizens were not seeing
the promise of their vote realized.
SIERRA: The Voting Rights Act was signed into
law at the height of the Civil Rights Movement,
and it prohibited racial discrimination in voting.
In 2013, the Supreme Court struck down parts of
the law. Some saw this as a victory for states’
rights. Many others have seen it differently.
CLARKE: The court basically brought to a grinding
halt a core piece of the Voting Rights Act that
applied to parts of our country that had very long
and egregious histories of voting discrimination.
Many states in the south like Mississippi,
Louisiana, Alabama, South Carolina, Florida,
Texas, were included as well and a number of
other states. But before they could make changes
to voting, before they could purge people from the
rolls, before they could shut down polling sites,
they had to get federal review, largely carried
out by the Justice Department. And that federal
review process looked to see whether the voting
change would harm or worsen the position of Black
voters, Latino voters, and other voters of color.
And that provision of the law was remarkable in
blocking and deterring a lot of voter suppression
and a lot of voting discrimination. And since
that Supreme Court ruling, we've literally just
seen the floodgates of voter suppression open up
across our country. And it's resulted in a lot
of setbacks, a lot of reversals in progress,
and a lot of litigation by civil rights
organizations, like my own. We are we are
fighting to make sure that all communities
are able to have voice in our democracy.
SIERRA: When it comes to overall turnout
in the United States, issues of race,
gender and vote suppression are very real factors.
But there’s a lot of other important factors,
too. There’s the complex psychology of what
actually leads someone to exercise their vote.
And a vast system of differing local rules
to navigate. It’s a lot! And there are some
great resources in the show notes if you want
to dig deeper. But, it’s also worthwhile to look
outward at what other countries are doing that
seems to be working for them. Take… Australia.
DIXON: Australia has a record of close to 100%
turnout, which is one of the things we're very
proud of. Voting in Australia is compulsory.
And what that means is that you have a legal
obligation to vote in every election, state,
federal and local. You have a choice between
paying a penalty and showing up to vote. And the
penalty is actually not very high. It's around
$100. And you can write a letter and explain why
you can't pay it or why you had a good reason
for not voting. So, you know, many countries,
indeed dozens of countries around the world,
have mandatory voting. But, they have high turnout
and much higher turnout than the US, but something
quite, distinctly lower than Australia. So
the mandate alone is not the explanation.
SIERRA: So it's not just the mandatory
voting law. How would you categorize
the major factors that have led to
such a high turnout in Australia?
DIXON: Well, I think voting in
Australia is relatively easy,
it's made to be as enjoyable as
possible as a kind of social practice,
and there's a strong social norm that voting
is expected as a responsibility of citizenship.
SIERRA: So, Australia’s recipe
for turnout actually has four
ingredients. Mandatory voting, sure.
But also, easy voting. A shared sense
of civic responsibility and something
you might not expect. Enjoyable voting.
SIERRA: When we say enjoyable,
what do you mean? Like, it's
fun to vote? Or it's a big party,
like what do you mean, enjoyable?
DIXON: Closer to a party. Now, you
know, in COVID, there are no parties,
right? But the tradition in Australia is you show
up at your local polling station on a weekend,
there are people there handing out how to vote
cards, but there's also like a hotdog stand
and a cake stall and you see people from the
neighborhood. So it's closer to a potluck. And
there's definitely a sense that you go up, you can
take your kids and your dog and you can see your
neighbors and chat; not just, you know, show up
in a line. And that's part of what makes it easy,
right? You show up and you're like, this is
actually kind of pleasant. I'll see my neighbors,
I'll have a chat and it's not a chore. It's
almost like Fourth of July in terms of the
degree to which people have made it fun and you
know, something that's part of the social fabric.
SIERRA: Hotdogs aside, to many Americans,
a mandatory voting law could feel like a
constraint on freedom. But many Australians
have come to see the law as more of a
signpost than a constraint, something
that builds voting into the social fabric by
establishing a sense of shared responsibility.
DIXON: So law can do two things. One is it can
really coerce people to do the right thing when
they want to do otherwise, right, it can be a
really important kind of moral and coercive force.
But sometimes law just coordinates our behavior.
So whether we drive on the left or the right hand
side of the road, something I've had to remind
myself of from time to time living in the US and
Australia, is not something anyone wants to get
wrong. No one wants to be in a head on collision,
right? So the law tells us to drive on the
left or the right hand side. But it's not
really needing to coerce us, it's just sending
a signal to people of what's expected so we can
all coordinate and get it right. And on one
view, that's what mandatory voting laws do
in Australia and elsewhere, they don't actually
force us to do the right thing. They just send
a signal to citizens that everyone's going to
vote. And so the social norm is we all show up.
SIERRA: And this brings us to
the final ingredient, “ease.”
DIXON: I think, actually, all of them are mutually
reinforcing, but I think it's the most important,
so it is always on a weekend. And they make
sure it's not on a weekend that clashes with
some major event. So you cannot have it on the
day of a major sporting final, for instance,
because then people would be outraged that they
have to miss the sporting finals. There's really
good pre polling, there's good postal voting.
So basically, you almost never wait more than
about 15 to 30 minutes. And there's a sense
in which that is linked to pretty effective
controls on voter suppression. So they don't
make it really hard to prove identity and to
get the vote counted. And for regular full
time workers, it doesn't clash with work,
you don't have to, you know, have a boss who
supports you, you can just show up to vote.
SIERRA: So beyond grabbing rights,
why does high turnout even matter?
DIXON: One of the things that happens when
you have a system where everyone votes is that
politicians modify their own behaviors in their
own policies to respond to the likelihood that
there will be large turnout, and that they are
appealing to the median voter and not simply their
base. And that's one of the best parts of a system
of compulsory voting is it drives the kind of
policy behaviors from major parties that are truly
about serving ordinary folks and the median voter,
not the extreme polls of our polity, and only
seeking to appeal to a party space. I think it's
important to note the similarities between the
US and Australia, but also the idea that every
country is ultimately different. Australia
is not the US, the US is not Australia,
we're a 10th of the size, we have more of a mix
of American and social democratic traditions. But
I do think there's really important similarities.
We are a federal system that borrowed heavily from
the United States, we have the same common law
tradition and set of constitutional guarantees
around judicial independence. And we have
a degree of cultural similarity, which is,
we're much more pro-free market and individual
responsibility than Canada, for instance,
right? So I always think of Australia as kind
of midway between Canada and the US culturally,
we have more of a welfare state, we have more
of a sense of collective responsibility for the
people who fall through the cracks. But we're
more free market and entrepreneurial. And we're
more American in our sense of the frontier
and a sense of entrepreneurship. But you know,
we're not the same. And no country is
the United States. You cannot find a
country that's identical. So, you know, I think,
Gabrielle, you've spent some time in Australia,
you would see it as similar and different.
But I would say the Australian model has
lots of downsides in other contexts, but
this is one of our absolute best exports.
SIERRA: So Australia is full of good ideas. And
it seems like they’re working. But what seems
easy and natural in one country can be quite
difficult to implement in another. After the
break, we turn to David Becker to discuss
the feasibility of adopting Australia’s
examples. But first, a few more global Why It
Matters listeners on voting around the world.
REBECCA: Hi my name is Rebecca, and I am
a Singapore citizen and I voted for the
first time in our general election this year.
Voting is fairly straight-forward in Singapore,
voting is mandatory so we always
get a turnout of about 97 percent.
SPEAKER: Voting in Kenya can be very
intimidating. We have a very long
history of election-related violence. You’re
likely to encounter very very long lines,
normally when you vote you are also
asked to give your fingerprints so
anybody who votes has blue ink on
their hands for a couple of days.
SIERRA: Hello listeners! So if you dig all
the questions we ask in Why It Matters,
you are going to love this other podcast
brought to you by our friends over at
Pushkin Industries. It’s called Solvable. Kind
of a natural fit. Solvable is a weekly podcast
where Malcolm Gladwell, Anne Applebaum, and
Jacob Weisberg ask how we can find solutions
to some of the biggest issues of our time.
You’ll hear from David Baltimore on AIDS,
Sal Khan on basic education, and Roseanne Hagerty
on homelessness. These problems can seem too big
or too complicated to fix. But in the hands
of the right people -- activists, scientists,
policymakers and politicians at the top of their
fields -- there are ways to solve them. And that’s
the hopeful message of Solvable. Listen and
subscribe now in your favorite podcasting app.
SPEAKER: In the UK until 2011, a Prime Minister
could call an election whenever they wanted.
Since then though, we have had scheduled general
elections that take place every five years on the
first thursday in May. One odd quirk about the
UK system, is that you don’t need ID to vote.
SPEAKER: In Switzerland we’ve
had mail-in voting for years now,
I haven’t voted in person in, probaby,
25 years. We are also automatically
registered to vote when we turn 18,
so the whole process is super easy.
SIERRA: And we are back. So, as promised,
let’s ask David Becker about some of the
ingredients that combine to make
Australian voting such a success,
and see if he thinks they can work in the States.
SIERRA: So, first one is instituting a
national voter holiday or weekend voting.
BECKER: One of the things I worry about is
there's other things that go along with a
national holiday — there are school closures,
public transportation office often is on a
reduced schedule, and hourly employees who are
often the people who we most want to hear from,
whose voices are not as loud as they could
be, they often might be incentivized to work
more by earning more wages on a national
holiday than they would on an ordinary day.
SIERRA: How about a national voting registry,
one of these magic lists that you mentioned?
BECKER: That's very common in most established
democracies in the world. We have never had that
in the United States. And in fact,
we rely upon individual state voter
lists. And that's actually even fairly a recent
development, up until about fifteen years ago,
many states still retained lists solely at
the county or local level. And so having
fifty state voter lists, and often trying to
integrate that with a motor vehicles agency,
which is probably one of the data sources that has
the most people in it can be really helpful, but
it's not as good as a unified citizen registry.
So I think there's a couple of barriers to this,
one coming from the right and one coming from the
left. I think the right is reasonably concerned
about issues related to privacy and federalism
in creating a single national master database of
all citizens. And I think the left is worried
that such a database could be used to cause
difficulties or even deport people who may not
be citizens, whether they're here legally or not.
SIERRA: Okay last one, what about mandatory
voting as something that the US could implement?
BECKER: There are some who talk about some kind
of compulsory voting requirements in the United
States and whether it's possible. Again, I'm not
against it. I think it's highly unlikely. I think
we have some things like the First Amendment that
possibly collide with that. Although there’ve been
some suggestions about ways to avoid First
Amendment free speech-compelled speech kind
of issues, and they're thoughtful
approaches. But I will tell you,
I just don't think there's any political will
to move in that direction right now. I don't
think it's highly likely that we'll see that
in the United States anytime soon. And I think,
you know, I'm going to focus my efforts
on making compulsory voting moot,
because people want to vote. And that's what I'd
like to see done more. And I think, and as I said,
we're still learning about that so much,
that's going to take a lot of time.
SIERRA: There’s no silver bullet. In
Australia, these policies are part of
a social fabric that has grown organically
around them. America has its own culture,
and its own norms, and that means that
no single policy from another country can
fix the problem. If you try to import the rule
without the social norms, you’re in for trouble.
And that leads to a deeper question - how do you
change a voting culture? Not just for a single,
dramatic election, but in the
long term, across the spectrum?
BECKER: I think there's pretty good evidence that
civic education in the United States has gone
down over the course of the last forty to fifty
years. This has been in conjunction with efforts
to delegitimize our democratic system. I mean,
there has been efforts to portray our system of
democracy as simply a game with winners and losers
and they're playing the game against each other,
and they're trying to get whatever advantage
they can. That's not a very constructive way
to run a democracy. This is more than a game.
So we have to take it a little more seriously
and reject efforts to portray this as a horse
race. You know, we're in litigation right now
where we see a lot of rules being changed in
the election process by people who think that
certain rules will benefit or harm their party
prospects. Look, that's just simply wrong. And
we have to be willing to accept a world where
our candidates might lose and accept that that
is an important democratic lesson. If we have 100
percent turnout and my preferred candidate loses,
I consider that a big win. And we're
not even close to there right now.
CLARKE: I think about 2020, I mean, this is a
moment where people are, marching and protesting
in ways that we've not seen previously for a
response to the crisis of police violence and
racial violence that has long gripped our nation.
These marches and protests, I think, are signs
of hope for long overdue reform. But I wonder if
people also realize that their votes are another
powerful weapon for achieving reform on those
issues. So you know, do people understand that
the district attorney is an elected position,
right, and that district attorney is the one
that's looked to to decide whether or not to
prosecute an officer who used deadly force without
basis on an unarmed African American? Do people
understand that the mayor is the one that often
gets to decide who serves as police chief? So when
I think about voter education, I'm thinking about
getting people access to accurate information.
And I'm also thinking about empowering people
so that they understand what their votes mean.
And, you know, I often hear from people as I
travel and do this work that, who's occupying 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue doesn't impact whether or not
I can get food on the table, or whether I'm able
to get a job, and I do think that for those folks
there is a little bit of work to do in
understanding how power manifests itself.
SIERRA: In an ideal democracy, everyone
understands the power of their vote,
and everyone uses it. And look, of
course there are no ideal democracies,
each comes with its flaws. But it’s worth noting
that the same countries that top the voter turnout
list - Australia, Denmark, Norway, and Sweden
for example- also top the most trusted global
indices for quality of life and democratic
freedoms. Correlation is not causation,
but the trendline is there. And that may be
because high turnout forces politicians to
come up with policies that address the needs of
large groups of people, rather than the needs of
their followers. But to get there, you need an
electorate with a shared educational baseline.
BECKER: I think we're doing better in
many ways than we've ever done before.
But I think we need to educate our children and
educate our media about what the end goal of
democracy is. The end goal of democracy is not a
period of time during which you can stand on the
top pedestal and be declared the winner. The end
goal of democracy is to better living conditions
and the environment for our fellow citizens.
And if democracy doesn't serve that role,
then we have to ask ourselves, why are we
engaged in it? And that's, of course, what
our adversaries want. There are people who are
in power solely because they subvert any efforts
of democracy in their country. And they benefit
from that, and so when we doubt that, they win.
SIERRA: What reforms would you most like to see?
BECKER: So, I think one of the things I'm
seeing from this election cycle is theres
such an effort to try to game the system
and change the rules close to an election,
when the political dynamics are largely set.
And what I'd like to see in an off year when
the political dynamics are still very vague,
we're not sure who's going to be benefited by
certain things, an effort to bring Republicans
and Democrats together to try to establish some
common rules for the process. I think our
decentralization is good in many ways. But
I do think we probably need to do more to
establish a national floor. In other words,
what's a minimum that every state can do?
Every state should probably offer no-excuse
mail voting options. Every state should probably
offer some degree of early voting. Every state
should allow for correction of problems with
ballots to some degree. And probably, you know,
every state should also have a standard for when
ballots are received. And one of the problems
we face right now is there's no federal law
that says these things, and it's not in the
Constitution. And so there's a lot of vagueness,
and I think one of the things I'd like to see
during the off years is an effort to try to
resolve some of these issues and avoid some
of this litigation by the parties who are trying
to game the system one way or the other. The rules
should be set well before we start playing,
and we're not really quite there. We probably
experience a lot more pre- and post-election
litigation than almost any other country.
CLARKE: I would love to see same day voter
registration. There are, you know, a lot of
people who I think, miss out on the opportunity
to vote because of just really restrictive
timelines for getting registered. In states
that have same day registration like Minnesota,
those states enjoy some of the highest turnout
and participation rates in the country. I'd love
to see what it would look like if we had voting
on weekends in our country, when people have a
little bit more flexibility and latitude. I'd love
to see automatic voter registration. I'd love to
see more voter education and election officials
that are kind of really in the 21st century when
it comes to how they communicate with voters. I'd
love to see pre-registration, kids who can get
registered at 16 and 17. And then I'd love to see
Congress finally restore the Voting Rights Act.
BECKER: It's kind of a vicious circle,
as our elected leaders at some levels are
less representative of our electorate,
perhaps the diverse electorate sees less
of a connection between them and what
government is doing and they check out and don't
participate which leads to a furtherance of a
less representative set of leaders. And to some
degree, we need to break that vicious cycle. And,
if we can get more people to turn out more
regularly—young people, people of color, people
who are not socio-economically advantaged—these
are all people who participate in much lower
rates, we could see leaders getting elected that
represent their interests a little more and in
turn those voters will continue to see that their
interests are represented and they may be more
inclined to participate. And maybe we get into a
much more constructive cycle if we can get there.
SIERRA: It’s a hard thing to fix. Especially
in the United States, which is larger,
messier, and more diverse than many of
the countries topping the turnout list.
But difficulty is never a good reason not to try.
Low voter turnout creates a gap between what U.S.
citizens want and what their government actually
does. And that’s true of foreign policy just as
much as domestic policy. The more Americans vote,
the more our policies on China, trade, climate
change, and all the rest reflect the actual
worldviews of American citizens. Low turnout also
undercuts our credibility on the world stage,
and it allows our adversaries to point out
hypocrisy when we support democracy abroad.
BECKER: I mean, I guess the last message I have
is one of optimism and hope. I mean, you know,
we've not always done as well as we could
here in the United States. We have not always
had the level of participation that we could
expect. We have not always nominated leaders
who reflect our best selves. But we often
self-correct. And we often find ways to bring
back the best in ourselves at certain points
in time. And there have been times when we've
seen a dark period followed by a period of hope
and a period of participation and engagement.
One of the things I'm inspired by every day, as
a lot of us are working crazy hours in these last
few days of the election, is the American voter.
I'm supposed to be giving them information and
providing a better system for them, and instead
they're giving me inspiration every day. I see
lines showing up to vote early. I'm seeing people
returning mail ballots in rates they've never done
before. I see people educating themselves about
a process which is tough. They're in a pandemic.
We're experiencing foreign interference and
disinformation. I'm continuously inspired
by their will to have their voice heard in
this election. I'm relatively confident that
we're going to see that heard loud and clear. And
hopefully within the few days after Election Day,
we'll have a really clear direction
for this country that is hopeful.
Sérgio Teixeira Jr.: Hello my name is Sérgio
Teixeira Jr. and I am a journalist from Brazil.
Voting is mandatory in Brazil, between
the ages of 16 and 18 you are allowed to
vote but you don’t have to. And in Brazil for
decades now we have been voting electronically.
Alexandra: Hi my name is Alexandra and I’m
from Sweden. In Sweden elections always take
place on Sundays, which means that most people are
able to go and vote during the day without having
to take time off from work. People are encouraged
to vote and some schools even hold their own
elections as part of an initiative called Skolval
or school election in which students get to vote.
These votes aren’t part of the official election,
but it gives many young people an insight into the
voting process and there are often discussions and
events happening around these school elections.
SIERRA: The time has come for me to tell our
American listeners to go vote. And that’s just
what I’m going to do. There’s not a single
global issue that we’ve discussed on Why
It Matters that you don’t have the chance
to influence with your vote. Worried about
climate change? Vote about it. Want the world to
focus on pandemic readiness? Step into the booth.
And when it comes to the problem of turnout,
your vote addresses the issue directly. You
get to fix it, by voting yourself,
and by doing everything you can to
encourage those around you to do the same.
So do it. Enjoy it. It’s a powerful thing.
For resources used in this episode and more
information, visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes. Additionally, CFR
has some amazing election related content so be
sure to check out cfr.org/election2020. Know
a young voter-to-be who wants to learn more
about how the world works? Tell them to check out
World 101 - its a growing library of multimedia
resources that explain international affairs
and foreign policy issues to learners young and
old. It's been a priority for the Council, and
it's really worth checking out. Have an idea?
Have some feedback? Want to just say hey?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio. And if
you like the show, please leave us a review!
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations. The show is created and
produced by Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me,
Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer is Markus
Zakaria and our intern is Senniah Mason. Robert
McMahon is our Managing Editor, and Doug Halsey
is our Chief Digital Officer. Sending endless
appreciation to all of the amazing people
around the world who gave us their election
day descriptions, we loved listening to them.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
We also used a snippet of an awesome track by
Australian musician Xavier Rudd. Special thanks
go to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke. Special
thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle
Sierra signing off. See you at the polls!